字幕: Masako Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
すごいプレッシャーをかけられました
（笑）
しかも表題は「役に立つか」なんて言って
自分で自分を否定する自虐的な表題に
なっちゃっているんですけれども
それを反論してみたいと思います
それで 皆さんの中で歴史が好きだっていう方
どれくらいいらっしゃいますか？
ちょっと手を挙げてください
高校までの歴史で 好きになっちゃったとか
もう嫌になっちゃったっていう人
どのぐらいいらっしゃいますか？
なんか礼儀をわきまえた人が
多すぎるみたいですね
（笑）
いや実際はですね 私がよく聞くのは
特に 理系の人がですね
「もう歴史なんて本当に嫌だった」
っていうことをよく聞くんですね
で 無理もないです
これ （笑）
［詳説 世界史］［詳説 日本史］
見覚えがあると思うんですが
東大で歴史を受験科目に選んだら
こうなっちゃいますね
この教科書をまず見るというのが
基本だと言われています
中身は確かに良いものだろうと
私は思いますけれども
でも はっきり言ってあんまり面白くない
（笑）
私自身も読み返したいと思いません
ですから こういうのを読んで
受験勉強をした人はこういう風に考えています
[歴史は暗記科目？]
無理もない
だけれども 私自身 これを読んで
そこに出てくる単語を無理やり覚えたり
さっきの年代を覚えたりって
大変苦痛に思います
なんて言うか 知的な虐待をしているん
じゃないかって感じがすることがある
でも実際に 私がですね
歴史の研究をやっている場合は
面白くてたまらないわけですね
こういう教科書のイメージと
実際私たち歴史家が研究しているものは
随分違います
で それをちょっと
今日話してみたいんですね
で もうひとつ 歴史に対する
批議というか批判というのはですね
「未来を生きるのが 我々にとって大切だ
だからその時に
過去の知識なんか要るわけがない」
こういう風におっしゃる方が随分います
実際 あの … 社会が豊かになってくる時
建国の時とか復興の時は
「歴史が大事だ」「 自分たちは団結しよう」
となるんですけれども
社会が豊かになってくると
どの国でもですね
私の同業者は
韓国であろうと 中国であろうと
「なんか 最近学生の歴史に
対する関心が薄れてきた」
「困ったな 」というような話を聞きます
で そういうことに対して
私がどう言うかというと
やっぱり それは違う
［否］
［たとえば、］
良い例がですね 例の東日本大震災でして
福島原発が事故を起こしたのも
千年か２千年に１回しか起きないような
大きな津波が起きるっていうことを
無視してたというところから来ています
専門家は気が付いていたんだけれど
多くの人はそれを無視したと
ですから 長期で起きる問題っていうのは
非常に身近なところで問題に
なることもよくあるわけです
そうするとやはり 過去の知識って結構
大事だということなんですね
そしてさっき 司会の
福井さんがおっしゃったように
ネガティブなことばっかりが
歴史の中にあるかというと そうでもなくて
結構 「これすごいな」
ということもあるんですね
それが 私が専門にしております
「明治維新」の研究っていうものです
で これはですね あのー
明治維新というと 皆さん
どういうことを思い浮かべられますかね？
多分 「王政復古」だとか
「廃藩置県やった」とか
それから 「文明開化を始めた」とか
こういうところだと思うんです
ただ 多分あなた方が
あんまり気が付いていない
非常に重要な現象があるんですね
「犠牲者が少なかった」
大体トータルで
３万人ぐらいです
３万人と言うと
皆さん 「そんなにいたのか」
とおっしゃるかもしれませんが
［明治維新　犠牲者の少ない革命］
明治維新に先行する
フランス革命の場合はですね
全体で２百万人ぐらい
亡くなっているんですね
当時のフランスの人口は
日本の明治維新の頃の８％と小さかった
ですから この間に
２桁の犠牲者の数が違う
ここは 意味がある
で どうしてじゃあ 明治維新はそんなに
犠牲者が少なくて済んだのだろう
ということが問題になる
で 答えは大変難しいですよね 本当に
だけど 多分これはひとつの解答だろう
という風に考えられるものがあったんです
これは 明治維新の過程をですね
図示したものです
非常に簡略化してありますが
で 一番下が
例の明治維新の出発点と
考えられるペリーの来航でして
ここから始まって
上の方に時間が動いていって
最後に行き着いたのは何かというと
侍がいなくなったと
世界的に見て 侍というのは
まあ 貴族の一種ですね
で 大名とか 侍とかがいなくなってしまった
これは大したもんなんです
そして華族とか 皇族とか ごく一部 —
400家ぐらいだと思いますが —
その人たちを除いて あとの日本人は
全員が同じ権利を持つようになりました
近代世界史上 最大の革命の１つです
しかしながら その犠牲は少なかった
なんでだろう？
で この図でですね
出発点は 西洋の国々がやってきて
どうも世界の他の所を見ていると
日本も侵略されるかもしれない
「これは困った」というのが出発点だ
これは ずっと明治維新の間
一貫して心配されたことでした
じゃあその時にですね —
日本を守らなきゃといった時にですね —
最後に行きついた所
つまり大名や侍をなくすことが
できたでしょうか？
日本を守れたのは 当時は侍しかいなかった
ですから 出発点では絶対に
侍をなくそう 世襲身分をなくそうと
いうことは あり得なかったのです
そうすると このゴールに向かって直進する
っていう形で 明治維新は起きていない
むしろ「迂回路」を取った
で この迂回路を取ったっていう場合にも
意識的にやった場合と
無意識にやった場合があります
明治維新の後半はですね
実はこれを意識的にやった場合なんです
それは王政復古の直後からですね
薩摩・長州をはじめとするリーダーたちは
「次の課題は廃藩である」と
「天皇の下に 日本の国家を
１つの国にしてしまう」と
江戸時代みたいな 約260ぐらいの
国家を連合した連邦国家でなくて
ひとつの国家に変えてしまおうと思った
だけども これを口に出さないんですね
実際に軍事力も財力も
大名の下に集結されている —
なくすわけにはいかない
どうするか？
間にクッションを挟んだんですね
で 廃藩の直後に明治政府のリーダーの
１人だった木戸孝允という人がいますが
彼が日記にですね —
３年半ぐらいでこれ（革命）を
やってのけたのですが —
ここに至るまでに
大変な苦労したと言っています
で その苦労したことの工夫の１つが
間にクッションを挟んだ
「版籍奉還」として知られているものです
江戸時代の習慣を利用しました
江戸時代ではですね
徳川将軍の代が変わった時に
大名たちは皆 統治許可証を
貰っていたのを 一遍返して
新しい将軍から貰うことになっていました
ですから 今度 将軍がいなくなって
天皇が新しい日本の支配者になったんだから
まずその天皇に統治許可証を返そう
と言ったら あんまり抵抗がないわけです
で 返したら 新政府は返してくれない
（笑）
騙したなと
大名たちはもちろん怒らないんですね
元と同じ土地を治めるようになりましたが
それは 明治政府の官僚として
治めるということになる
そして その２年後には
大名全体をなくしてしまったと
で こういう風に 意識的に迂回作戦をやった
これが明治維新の後半の出来事です
それに対してですね
しかし幕末の間 十数年の戦争の中でも
似たようなことが起きているぞと
意識的にやったんじゃないけれども
知らず知らずのうちに迂回路に
はまったんじゃないかってことがあります
それはここに書いてありますが
日本を守ろうって言った時に 最初にですね
これは大事だから
認めましょうと言われたのが
「公儀 」「公に儀する」ってことです
幕府の外にいる人たちが
「日本の将来こうやった方が良い」
ということを提案する
それまでは 政治的な意見を述べること
公の場で述べることは
一切禁止されていました
幕府の役人ですら自分の担当以外のことに
口を挟んではいけない
それが 安政５年に大きな政変が起きた時に
そのタブーが解かれたんですね
そして 皆がこうしよう
ああしようと議論を始めて
10年経って 王政復古になりました
で 王政復古のアイデア自体は
実は「公儀をやろう」と言葉が
出てきた直後に生まれていて
順序としては公儀の方が先だったんですけども
ともかく ああだこうだと
10年やっているうちに王政復古に行きついた
王政復古に行きついたら
「次は単一の国家を作ろう」と
こういう風に動いていったわけです
ですから これを全体として見ると
大きな迂回路を通って このゴールに到達した
で 直進は一切不可能ですよね
日本を守ろうっていう時に 侍はなくせない
だけども 迂回路をとったために
最終的に素晴らしい結果が生まれた
「日本人全員平等」と
こういう風になりました
というわけで こういうことを説明すると
外国の人たちはかなり興味を持ってくれて
いろんな社会がいろんな問題を抱えていて
その時に大鉈を振らなきゃいけないという風に
大きな問題を抱えている社会もあります
何もしないわけにはいかない
しかしながらその時に直進をしたら
これはもう 必ず抵抗に遭う
大きな抵抗に遭うということは
犠牲者がいっぱい出る
だけれども その時迂回路を
取れば 抵抗は少ない
１つ１つは大事なことだから
皆一緒に協力してやりましょうと
いうことになる可能性はあるわけです
ということで 明治維新の研究の中からは
抜本的な社会改革っていうものを
犠牲を少なくしてやるという
可能性が見えてくるんですね
それからもうひとつ
「これから 未来の我々 人類の社会は
どうなるか」ってことが問題で
「これが今の我々の生き方のその延長上に
あるのだろうか」っていうことがある
私はないんじゃないかと
歴史の中で しょっちゅう
人々が当たり前だと思っていることが
覆っているケースがあって
例えば 江戸時代の人たちは
「鎖国がずっと続く」と思っていた
「それで日本の平和がもう２百年 ３百年
４百年続くだろう」と思っていた
それは 実現しなかった
で 今の日本がどれほどのエネルギーを
消費しているかというと このグラフです
細かいところを別にすれば
とにかく趨勢的にエネルギー消費量が
上がっていっています
そして エネルギー消費量が
増えているのは日本だけでなく
もっと急激に増えているのは世界最大の
人口大国である 中国であり インドです
で 他の地域も経済成長を目指している
人間 一遍欲望に目覚めたら元に戻れません
ですから 世界全体のエネルギー消費は
益々増えていくに決まっています
そうすると我々が今使っている化石燃料
石油とか —
シェールオイルも今 使えるように
なりましたけども —
それがいくら増えたところで限界が
あるんじゃないか と思われるわけです
そうすると 今の生活の延長上に
未来を考えるというひとつのシナリオ —
非常に強いシナリオですが
それ以外のシナリオも考えておく
必要が出てくると思うんですね
その場合 多様なシナリオを考える必要がある
どれが当たるか 未来のことは分かりません
いくつか考えておかないといけない
で そのときに私は ひとつは定常社会を作る
成長っていうことがない社会を作る
というのもあるだろう と思いますね
で これについて日本史は
非常に面白い例を提供していて
江戸時代の日本がそうです
これは江戸の芝居小屋の
あった街の絵ですけれども
［「いま・ここ」と異なる社会の実例］
今我々が生きているのとは
全然違う社会でした
そこでは人々は「社会が発展しない」
という前提の下で生きていました
研究によって ゆっくりとであったけれど
経済成長があったことは分かっている
社会構造も少しは変わりました
しかし 人々は体感できない
そうすると 「発展を前提としないで
どうやって楽しく生きるか」っていうのが
江戸時代の人々の一番重要な関心です
で それがよく分かるのは
幕末に西洋人が日本にやってきて
あちこち歩きまわって
いっぱい旅行記を書きました
その記述を見てると
「日本人は非常に穏やかで
物腰柔らかい人たちで 非常に礼儀正しい」
これは貴族だったら世界中みんな同じです
だけど日本の場合違うのは
庶民までそうだ
身分の卑しい貧しい人たちまで
非常に穏やかで物腰が丁寧だと言うんですね
多分 これは「そういう閉じられた
世界でどのように楽しく生きるか」
ということを考えたために
そうなったんだろうと思われるんですね
その具体的な工夫の例としては
有名な茶の湯がありますね
江戸時代っていうのは非常に
厳しい身分制度の社会です
身分が細かく分かれていて
いちいち下の人が上に物を言う場合は
言葉遣いに気を付けなきゃいけない
大名行列が向こうから来ると
本当は逃げた方が良いかも知れません
逃げれなかったら道端に土下座して
それを迎えなきゃいけない
非常に屈辱的な身分制
っていうものがありました
しかしながら そういう社会のど真ん中に
時と所を限って
身分がない空間を作ったのです
お茶室に入ると その時は
そこに招かれた人々は
大名であろうと 普通の侍であろうと
場合によっては商人であろうと
身分は同じになります
出ると戻ってくる
その限られた空間の中で
対等な交際を楽しむ
それからもっとこれが後の世に
重要になったのは 学校です
江戸時代の学校の主力は
私塾だったんですけど
私塾の中のかなりの部分が
そこに学んでいる時だけは
身分が消えてしまって
年齢も消えてしまって
そして 学問的実力だけで
席次を考えるという
そういう習慣があるんです
そういう風に閉じられた硬い社会であっても
そこに「ゆとりを作る」
「息継ぎができる空間を作る」と
そういう工夫がなされていたのです
ということで 定常社会って
いろんなタイプがありえるかもしれない
江戸時代そのままだったら
本当に私は嫌です
嫌ですが それでも
「定常社会がどういうものであるべきか」
というのを考えるときに
江戸時代は参考になるだろうと思います
SFを作ったり アニメを作ってる人は
いろいろ面白いアイデアを
我々に提供してくれているけど
これは 実際にあった話なのですね
ということで 歴史の中には非常に
様々な知的な蓄積があります
宝庫です
それを参照しながら
その都度自分の都合に合ったものを
工夫していくということが
歴史を参照をすることによって
可能になるんですね
[「歴史」とは
「未来」のための経験貯蔵庫である]
これを 有名なドイツの政治家
ビスマルクがこう言っていますね
「愚者は経験に学び 賢者は歴史に学ぶ」
[愚者は経験に学び 賢者は歴史に学ぶ]
愚者というのは 我々普通の凡人で
自分の経験で失敗すると
二度と失敗しないように努力して
次のときはうまくやる —
それを積み重ねています
失敗経験の反省というのは
非常に重要なことですね
しかし 事と次第によっては
失敗したら二度と取り返しが
つかないことがある
人が大量に死んでしまうようなことがある
ですから 自分の経験だけに頼っていたら
もはや手遅れということもあるんです
そういうときには他人の経験を
参照する必要がある
その他人の経験の集積こそが
歴史に他ならないんですね
ということで ビスマルクに倣って
「愚者は経験に学び 賢者は歴史に学ぶ」
これは 我々にとって
とても大事な事だろうと思うんです
是非 高校の時の悪夢を
ちょっと頭の隅から消して
むしろ 本屋に行って
面白そうな本を手に取ってですね
「あ これ面白そうだ」と
片端から読んでください
きっと楽しいと思います
どうも有難うございました
（拍手）